this is a production of cornell
university
it's august 14th 2013.
we've had a very rainy season
and finally this is lemberger uh finally
verizon is starting to show up we're a
little bit late this year um because the
weather's been pretty poor
so uh i can tell that these these
clusters are starting to undergo a
raisin because
in something like
actually see the color change so what
happens at verizon is that we change
from stage through two excuse me to
stage three of fruit ripening and it
happens pretty rapidly so what happens
at raisin is we have berry softening so
these green berries here are still
pretty hard the red ones are quite soft
and i can actually compress them
reasonably easily
we see color changes and then a number
of things happen in the fruit basically
the sugars
rapidly start to increase
as measured by bricks
and the ph starts to increase and the
total or titratable acidity starts to
decrease so this is the final stage of
ripening it will still be another five
plus weeks until we harvest this
but this is when things really start to
happen and we can start to see that
things are on track
in terms of getting towards the end of
the season
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu